good afternoon everybody
and welcome to this meeting of
mid-suffolk district council cabinet
i'm councillor susie morley and i'm the
leader of mid-suffolk district council
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
can you please ensure that microphones
are turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not to post comments or questions
and please note that messages in the
chat panel
can be viewed by people watching the
live broadcast
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be
capable of repeated viewing the whole of
the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i will now ask the governance officer to
carry out the introductions
thank you chair in addition to the
cabinet members we have the following
councillors in attendance
councillor john field councillor andrew
stringer
and councillor keith wellam officers
attending the meeting today are the
chief executive arthur trevonier
monitoring officer emily yule strategic
director kathy nixon
assistant director to finance catherine
steele the assistant director for
housing gavin fisk
the assistant director for customer
services sarah wilcock
and the assistant director for
sustainable communities tom barker
thank you chair
thank you i'm now going to move on to
the agenda
item one is apologies for absence
thank you chair we have no apologies
thank you
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members
are there any to declare
no thank you very much item three
is mca 20 20-10
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the mid-suffolk cabinet
meeting
held on the 9th november 2020
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these minutes
could i have a proposal please uh thank
you chair yes happy to propose the
minutes
thank you councillor flatman and can i
have a second to please
um councillor fleming here i'm happy to
propose the minutes
to second the minutes thank you thank
you councillor fleming
the governance officer will now conduct
the electronic
vote thank you chair
councillors could you please open the
vote in the modern gov app
by clicking the plus sign in the top
right of the agenda screen
and select attendance and voting
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda item will show in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the votes
thank you councillors we now have
received all votes the result is nine
votes for
and that's unanimous thank you very much
so the minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed and will be signed at the next
practicable
opportunity item four to receive
notification of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
non-received thank you item five
any questions by councillors
non-received chair item six
matters referred by the overview and
scrutiny or the joint audit and
standards committees
there were none thank you thank you very
much
item seven the forthcoming decisions
list does anybody have any comments
no thank you item 8
is mca 20 11
and is the general fund financial
monitoring report for 2020
21 quarter two and i will now invite the
cabinet member for finance to introduce
this report
thank you madam chairman i'm grateful
for the opportunity to introduce cabinet
paper
mca 2011 the general fund financial
monitoring 2021 quarter two
which starts on page 13 of our reports
pack
every time i introduce one of these
finance monitoring reports i stress just
how important it is
that we keep a close eye on our
expenditure to date against budget
and carry out a third assessment to
forecast the outcome for the whole year
and that's just in normal times before
this new financial
year has even started covering 19 had
hit the uk
we found ourselves in lockdown we were
already putting into place processes
and procedures to help us track and
evaluate
the impact of this pandemic on our
council finances
and some of the earlier projections i
saw were frankly alarming
now even now eight months into the
pandemic we can still only make best
estimates of how the balance of the year
to 31st of march will pan out along with
other councils
we have collated and fed information
back to central government
and they in their turn have used that to
develop generous financial recompense
and assistance schemes
we are estimating the total impact of
covid on our general fund for the year
2021
at 2 million 335
000 pounds now various funding supports
from central government
are anticipated to total 2 million
208 000 pounds and these are all set out
in paragraph 5.8
although a very small part of that 47
000
will go to the housing revenue account
leaving 2 million
161 000 for the general fund
now the numbers shown in paragraphs 1.2
and 5.11
don't actually reflect the most up to
date position
the 81 000 pound mentioned in both those
paragraphs
should actually read 175 000 and the 96
mentioned should read 92.5
the schedule in paragraph 6.8 to set
out our current forecast so in a
nutshell
central government is covering 92.5
percent of our costs
and income losses leaving our council
with predicted covert impact
of 175 000 to fund
now all the detail behind these numbers
is set out in section 5 which runs to
several pages in the report
so rather than try to put any detail in
my introduction here i will instead be
happy to answer any questions members
may have
on these individual items now here in
mid surfer we do pride ourselves on our
careful financial management
and i said as i said at the start we
keep an eagle eye on our expenditure
and at this point we are anticipating
over one million pounds of savings
against budget
staff vacancy management which in some
cases will enforce due to lockdowns etc
should generate 450 000 other fundings
and savings
generate 573 000 with the details
described in section 6.6
the overall outcome in this most
difficult of years
is that mid-suffolk is forecasting a
surplus for the year
of 848 000 and that's a very
healthy surplus indeed in these coved
ravaged times
the report also sets out in detail our
capital programme with the spend to date
the full year forecast and details they
expected to carry forward
those numbers are in appendix d with
supporting narrative
in paragraph 615-617
appendices attached the report also set
out our reserves position
and the details of the continuing
projects in our growth and efficiency
fund
now i said when introducing the quarter
one monitoring report and it's worth
repeating again
my thanks to the finance team for
pulling together all this detail
whilst working from home it does require
excellent teamwork and coordination
whilst they're all working remotely from
each other
but i guess that's no different to all
of our council staff collectively
collectively they've all quickly adopted
so well
and performed magnificently i'd now like
to move the recommendation
set out in paragraph 3.1 but just
amended to read
that the council's general fund
financial position
at the end of quarter to be noted and
would ask for a second to please
thank you thank you councillor whitehead
do we have a seconder
mrs madam chair i'd be pleased to second
the uh recommendation and i'm delighted
actually to
endorse this report at a time when a
growing number of councils were at the
cliff's edge
in their finances msdc is
to put it conservatively well placed
in presenting his report councillor
whitehead rightly draws our attention to
that
to use his phrase in this most difficult
of years mid-suffolk
is forecasting a surplus of 848
000. this position isn't down to good
luck
it's a product of good financial
planning
a strong blend of prudence and
enterprise and above all
the unrelenting focus and hard work by
councillor whitehead
and the officer team the responsible
investment driven approach we have taken
means we can avoid
panic or re or regressive measures that
are the only unit
and inevitable choice for many
authorities and have the time and space
to plan
for a future that continues to be
uncertain and challenging
investments including commercial
investments through cifco
have made a significant contribution to
the strength
of the council's position and while the
recent comprehensive spending review
prohibits future pwlb borrowing for this
activity
early indications are that there may be
other sources of funding
to enable us to complete our investment
plans and so continue
to benefit the council's financial
position
thank you madam chair thank you for
second in that councillor gould
so do i have any questions from cabinet
members
councillor richardson
thank you chair um i've obviously
there's a lot of positive things i'd
like to say about this and i'd just like
to echo what counselor gould has said
but i'll i'll save that for the debate
um i just wanted one sort of question of
clarification on the earmarked reserves
um on page 30 of our report packs so
that's appendix c
um it looks as though from what i can
see um
that the 500 000 pot that we put aside
for climate change is being carried over
to the new financial year
um and i just wanted a bit of clarity on
that because my understanding and
perhaps council fleming could assist is
that there's already
you know a good chunk of that money
that's already being spent so any
clarification on that would be much
appreciated thank you
uh thank you council richardson i must
confess i was anticipating a question
like that because when i first saw the
report
and saw the fact that a half million
pound was there to be carried over
i was surprised i mean this is basically
taking the snapshot at the end of um
september before the biodiversity um
paper had gone to full council and the
reality is that
so much due diligence and hard work had
been going on
on the background for me for example we
had the climate change
uh group doing all the background work
and the reality is that um so much due
diligence needs to go into this before
we then start to
commit the money and the other thing i
would
certainly highlight is the fact that um
a lot of
environmental expenditure will not
actually ultimately show against this
half a million
now reasons for that is because so much
of our environmental expenditure
is embedded elsewhere within the general
fund and hra
some simple examples like the tree
planting tree for life
the funding of the grounds works today
to assess the council's emissions and
ongoing programme of work
you know that we're doing in our hras to
install cavity
and external wall installation and
ground source heat pumps
and a lot of the staffing costs are
already
expensed across the various council
budgets
and another thing which i've actually
found quite remarkable is that
we've made external bids totaling
675 000 for extra
environmental projects in this financial
year
and those sort of bids will include
things to grants for retrofitting our
homes
to take forward our solar car ports and
battery storage
to carry out the low carbon feasibility
for gateway 14
and develop the design guide but
basically
although the numbers as shown in this
quartz 2 report
show a zero figure uh an expenditure and
a full carry forward
i'm totally confident that come the end
of the year and come then
come the out turn that number will be
much lower
because so many things now are being
progressed
and i anticipate that expenditure
between now and the end of march
thank you councillor whitehead
councillor fleming would you like to
add add to that
thank you chairman i i would i think um
john has pretty much covered the
response but i just like to add
that um i do believe for one thing
two main points actually one thing i'm
not sure it's correct to assume
that nothing has been spent yet because
actually
we have already procured the services
of groundworks to do our baseline
assessment
we have agreed to procure the services
of suffolk wildlife trust
and we have um commissioned a
feasibility study
for the leisure center emissions um
as well as a lot of other ongoing
um work internally so um
the costs for the assessment of the
council's
emissions um you know
are part of our important baseline and
you know although that may not be
technically part of the 500 which
appears to remain in our reserves it is
nevertheless
an expenditure on the environment on the
climate change part of the environment
and we've also as i think on council
whitehead has pointed out done an awful
lot using opposite time
which has not come directly out of the
environment budget
and we've we're in the process of
preparing a design guide
and um i'd like to make a couple of
other good
other points about um this question
um councillor richardson i'd like to say
that good planning is essential
prior to spending any public money and
particularly 500 000 pounds at this time
is quite a lot and when the climate
change and biodiversity
motions were passed it was made clear
that our response needed to be
considered and targeted
rather than just um sort of thrown out
on the short term work and that
identified actions needed to be assessed
costed and agreed and that this would
all take some time and of itself
it would be irresponsible and a waste of
public money
to rush into projects that had not been
properly thought out
and on no account are we going to do
this
i'd just like to add one more thing
while i've got the floor that given the
relatively slow pace that all levels of
government
generally move i believe that we as a
district
have acted extremely quickly to respond
to the environmental commitments we've
made
and this response has taken an unusually
large investment of time and effort by
officers and councillors
over the past year which has been a
covered year and i think for this we
should all be very appreciative
thank you very much thank you very much
councillor fleming
so i'm going to move on now to questions
from non-cabinet members so if there's
any other
um people want to put your hand up the
cancer stringer
thank you chair oh i've got my wrong
i've got my wrong background forgive me
let me just put my correct background on
uh
that's the trouble with five meetings
per day uh
there we go uh sorry about that
apologies
uh yes i have i think six or seven
questions i'm afraid on this paper
um if i can quickly uh start asking them
page 15
could someone explain what a linear
recovery is
uh because linear is a straight line and
and economics rarely go in a straight
line
so someone could explain what linear
means uh
also and uh where it says
under 5.5 commercial income i really
don't
understand the sentence regarding
cifco and property rental income uh
where it says that we're receiving the
full loan repayments
but if this position changes the income
will be accrued
in the accounts for next year
uh or i i didn't quite understand that
because
cifco interest is one part of our income
and rental income is another part so i
couldn't quite see
how that sentence made sense if someone
could explain that to me
that'd be most helpful uh i also
uh on page 19 didn't understand
why we were seeing didn't see a
reduction in salary costs in waste
services
if we didn't actually give part of the
waste service
for a proportion of this year
that's the garden waste service
also on page 20 uh did we really really
have a
reduction in ict costs we i i would have
thought ict
costs frankly would have gone up during
this this period because we've relied
so heavily on it uh i think i'll leave
it there for that for the moment and
come back with another couple of
questions later if i may share thank you
okay councillor white hunter would you
like to respond i'm pulling
in all causes necessary yeah sure
hopefully i scribble those down
quickly um the first four um page 15 yes
it talks about
whether recovery is linear or not i
guess people talk about
v-shaped and w-shaped recessions and i
guess
we'll sit in my v's and w's are linear
but the reality is i
it probably will be a u-shape or or a
sort of
um non-linear um
recovery who knows i mean we thought
things have certainly picked up with the
um uh
well through the virus um uh
virus um now being approved and
everything and um
hopefully we'll soon be able to lock
down but um
yes it's it's not really easy to um
decide how the recovery will look
um paige a little section 5.5
and the sifko accrued income
and you're questioning i think the
difference between
rental income and accrued income well
the rental income will feature
in the books of cifco itself because
cifco earned the property
sifco received the rent and then sifko
itself has got borrowings
will pay interest to the council
and that income should cash flow should
flow through from the rental income
um if there are delays in getting that
rental income
into cifco and most most most of the
delays
we well most of the issues are
delays rather than lack of income then
that
cash flow may come through later but
because
we are still um confident
that that money will come through we can
accrue it in our books
so we'll take a crude interest in our
council books and then some
probably small part will follow as
actual cash flow
in the next year although the bulks in
this year
so i'm hoping that will answer that
question
worse waste services i mean my
understanding is
that all the waste services bar the
garden waste
functioned as normal during that period
but there were some of the surco
staff that went self-isolating or
went down with covered and i believe
they were still
paid and certainly i think it was a
requirement of government
that councils paid their um
service contracts and didn't try and
take any um
advantage from any of the issues there
so
that was the reason why um you wouldn't
see any
savings underway services
um i see t cost down
yes that does sound a bit like an
oxymoron let's have a look
page 20. um
so it's saying here um it's tributary
to review this suffolk county council
contract an issue is identified with
licensing budgets
um and that produced a saving of 90 000
um i mean to me that's it is what it is
but if any officer wants to
ship in with a bit more of a story
behind that i'd be happy for them to do
so
yes i'd like to invite the assistant
director for customer services sarah
wilcox to come in
thank you chair yes just to confirm um
that is correct in terms of uh
reduction in the costs attributed to our
main
ict contract with suffolk county council
and that's due to a timing issue with
respect to when the budget is set
um compared to when we actually agree
any final charges with suffolk county
which reflects some work that we did
around reducing the number of licences
that were required moving forwards
thank you thank you very much cancer
stringer did you have any more questions
i i do i have i have one uh
further question what we just covered
and two other small ones if i may thank
you
sorry to but it's quite a large document
so just
an explanation of the commercial income
what we're saying then is
if the cash flow into cifco as it were
starts to dry up that we would defer
payments from them to us as a council i
think is what you said
and i think that's what that language is
trying to say there
uh you you'll correct me if i'm wrong um
given on page 21 that we
have got another substantial underspend
on staffing costs are there any service
areas that we are
struggling to cover because obviously
that's a substantial amount of money
we're not spending also page
31 uh i was i was have to say quite
disappointed with the
amount of electric vehicle charging
point actual spend
given today the the we as a council are
saying that we're we're going to be
ahead of the game on this
i mean today braintree council uh opened
its 10 million pound facility
uh grid serve that opened today so uh i
just wanted to
you know express my disappointment that
our spending in that area
is is is not on track um like
reassurances that's going to catch up
and equally just wanted to just slightly
push back on the
uh success of of underspending 848 000
saying it's remarkable for this council
that is not remarkable that is normal
we normally underspend somewhere between
four and a half and eleven percent of
our budget
so frankly for for us this looks normal
in that we're either just not spending
our budgets
or we're not making realistic budgets in
the first place thank you chair
thank you
yes thank you um i think i do take
exception to your statement about
commercial income
drying up which to me is i think the
riverbed drying up
it which disappears i mean we're talking
really at the margin here because we've
got such a diverse portfolio of
properties
and increasingly diverse portfolio of
properties
the reality is that we've got one or two
issues
in one of two properties which are being
very quickly dealt with and by our
in-house and advisory team so
um you know we're talking really about
at the margins here rather than
you know the income drying up on page 21
uh underspend on staffing costs and
you're asking whether you feel
uh any services have been impacted by
that
i think if i may chair i'd like to pass
that to
our chief executive for his take on that
certainly arthur are you available to
help
yes sorry for the delay just while the
the system let me in
if you could repeat the question for me
castle stringer
sorry it seems to be running very slowly
yes given that there's quite a
substantial underspend on staff
salaries are there any areas of the
service
that that's impacted on in terms of not
being able to deliver that service
so not expressly no so the the reduction
in staff salaries is largely due to
to covet as you'll appreciate we were
running
a slightly higher vacancy rate as we
tend to talk about
um as we went into the covert period we
have been able to make some successful
recruitment during that period but not
at a normal level although that is now
beginning to recover
in reality any impact in terms of
service delivery
has been more directly to do with with
covered related responses
rather than to do with our staffing
intended numbers
because we've had to redeploy staff into
other areas so it's not so much that
we've had
a lack of staff and therefore not been
able to deliver but clearly i'd love to
be in the position always
of having yet more staff in order to do
all the additional things that you would
all like us to be able to do
day in day out but in this given year
and certainly our experience of it so
far
it's been more our response to the
pandemic than anything else that's had
the impact
thank you and then um in terms of
counsellor stringers
uh observations on page 31 about
electric vehicle charging points so
we take your comment on board um
you then mentioned you felt that we
normally underspend um but i think the
point i'm making here is
um this is an abnormal year so
to to come out with a pretty typical
normal underspend in an abnormal year i
still think is an achievement
thank you yeah councillor fleming did
you want to
respond with regard to the charging
points but
just very briefly um councillor stringer
i think you're probably aware from the
work of the climate change task force
that one of our actions
is to assess suitable locations and
numbers
um in terms of need for the points and
this is something the um
the officers and the group are working
on actively
at present so um it's not as if we're
rushing out to put in a lot of charging
points that
may or may not be in the right place
this again is a considered program we're
also working with
the county on its plug-in suffolk
program so that we've got some
coordination across the council in how
we um
service this need thank you thank you
councillor fleming
councillor welum
thank you chair i think i'm through now
um yeah i've got
a similar number of questions i'm afraid
but mine are very very straightforward i
think some of them are
just yes no answers so i'll kick off
with the first few
and and that most of them are to do with
the commercial income from
cifco and property rental income
um is that property income
property rental income other than from
cifco and
the former aldi building
and if so how has that been affected
um cifco is not currently collecting 100
percent of rental income
that's due um i understood it was
around 70 percent and maybe dropping
more towards 50 percent
um perhaps somebody can confirm but this
seems to be worse than one or two
problems with one or two properties
as councillor whitehead described it
um council is receiving a hundred
percent of loan repayments
so are these others so other these
repayments greater than
the rental income currently being
received by cifco
and if this situation continues
when will the situation be reached such
that cifco cannot make the planned
repayments
to the councils so shall i stop there
because they're all
they're all related to roughly the same
thing
yes let me get back on visible um
the uh in terms of
the commercial income other than cifco
and
you mentioned the the former supermarket
in stone market which is still in the
process of going through its um
various rent rental well getting tenants
on board
um i'm pretty sure there must be
other property income but i can't just
think of it straight away if our
family's on online and can can think a
little quicker than i i'm sure as soon
as she says it i'll
i'll remember them um but just before i
ask invite emily to come on board i mean
the information i've been given is that
um
the we're accruing at the end of quarter
to 685
000 pounds for commercialing uh
um interest from sifco and the actual
cash received is 592 000
so that is 86.4 percent as i calculate
it
the borrowing costs are only 269 000
over that
half year so in terms of head above
water well
i guess water's below waist deep
so from that point of view there's no
worry
worries um if emily can just answer
in terms of any other property income
yes if i can just bring in
assistant director for assets and
investments emily
good afternoon um yes we do have other
rental income
um that's received directly by
mid suffolk district council um it's
from
uh mainly a sort of small collection of
um
sort of small possibly community let's
might be the best
description so there's a nursery
building and some community centers
those types of um properties
so there's a small amount of rental
income that does come in that's
separate to the income that comes in
from cifco
thank you very much did you have any
other questions
yes um yeah um
my next question is in the middle of
that paragraph on commercial income
if this position changes the income will
be accrued in the
also i think now i think um councillor
string has asked that question
um so
i'm referring to the impact of covid on
future investments
is is the fact that further loans from
the
public works alone board will that will
that like be likely to have a bigger
impact than covid19
which page are you on councillor same
page
thank you right
obviously the consultation and the well
the feedback from that consultation on
the publix works loans board is pretty
much
hot off the press but the uh our section
151 officers have certainly
been speaking to all and close taking
their advice
and um basically changes to the pwlb
rules will prevent the council from
being able to borrow from pwlb
going forward but yeah and
in terms of either buying new properties
or converting short-term borrowings to
long-term
pdlb at a later stage um
basically now there will be other
sources of funding that we could
access to fund the last phase of the
civco purchases
and i think i think with we're certainly
making all efforts we can do
to prudently have that 100 million
invested across the two councils in
cifco by the end of march
because going forward beyond that the
council will not be able to borrow from
pwlb
whilst investing is undertaken um
in anything in civico beyond that point
so that pretty much is a cut-off point i
think
i think it's it's perhaps a bit
premature to start um
pontificating about the impacts we
haven't fully assessed all that yet
and this report is is really looking
backwards
so yeah we will be um officers will be
collaborating and coordinating with
councillor whitehead
going forward on this and peter and
counselor google i mean there's
certainly a lot of
work to still to do in this area in
terms of
any impact or what impact it will be on
budgets
for year 21 22. thank you jeff
it's just the council of gold in
seconding seemed very optimistic
that there would be um
loans available at very good rates and i
just wondered what that was being based
on
anyway we'll move on okay um did you
have another question
i've got three more but they're very
quick at the bottom of page 20
um what are the areas of investment
income that which are not performing as
expected
i'm just looking for page 20 as well now
um it's um investment income based on
performance today
our investments are not performing as
expected resulting in an adverse
variance of 83k i'm not
i don't want the the detail of them it's
just what sort of areas of
investment income are we talking about
are we talking about
short-term loans somewhere or um
sort of loaning money out or what what
are we what sort of thing are we talking
about
i i think to answer that and i'm i'm
pleased you aren't asking for the detail
because certainly i haven't got it to
hand
i would need to sort of dive into the
treasury management reports to dig that
out so i think
what we can do is provide you with
details of that well and all members
subscribe to this meeting i don't i
don't want the detail i just i'd just
like to know what sort of
what sort of income what sort of
investments are they are they property
investments are they
um financial investments i don't need
the detail well i suspect it all
it's this whole conglomeration whether
it's schroders
ccla and the various other investments
we've got so
without get i need to go into the detail
to find the difference
but we give you a sort of praise thing
let's put that yeah that's right i don't
want a detailed answer to it all
um community grants underspend
um she's on page 22.
um it says there
two thirds of the way down community
grant underspend of 58k
i just want to make sure that that at
the end of the financial year that will
be
transferred into next year's um
community grant
um budget not lost to community grants
because
obviously during the period of covid uh
most
most of these within my sort of area
most of the organizations that might
have put in
a bid for a community grant haven't done
so because
they need to sort of get together
physically and
and look at what what they would put the
grant uh
application in for so will that will
that still be ring fence to community
grants
i i don't feel confident to give you a
100 answer on that
but i'd like to think 99 that that would
be the case and
certainly if it's not then i will be
asking the question
if not why not uh and unless unless
there's a
very good reason that i'd hope it'd be
carry forward and trust it be carry
forward
now that i'm sorry on page 29
this is the growth and efficiency fund
there's
there's a line in there to do with
i think it's housing delivery business
growth
and in the first corner it says msdc
only
and then in the columns that follow
there are sums of money against baber
district council
so which page is this council whether
it's 29
yes you got a line number please it's
item
six ah right okay
and at the end of the words it says msdc
only
and then if you look to the right
there are numbers in the baby district
council column as well as
mid suffolk district council column
[Music]
um
well to me it does look like those
brackets shouldn't the words in brackets
shouldn't be there but if
if uh catherine steele would like to
make an
observation or we can get back to you
later whichever
catherine are you available to help yes
uh thank you thank you chair
um not off the top of my head i think i
would just need to take that away
and double check but um my uh
assumption would be similar to
councillor whiteheads that perhaps the
msdc only shouldn't actually be there in
brackets but we will confirm that
yeah because it actually looks like more
has been spent in baby than mid suffolk
i can just bring in arthur to help
thank you councillor molly i'm i may be
speculating here but if you look at the
column that's april
uh to september 2020 which is obviously
the two quarters that we're
we're relevant to discussing today the
spend for baber is zero
whereas there is some small spend for
mid suffolk so i don't know if that's
the
why the msdc has got only has gone into
the brackets
whereas obviously if you're looking at
the future commitments and the
communities spend to date then it's
relevant to both
that i'm speculating that might be the
reason
thank you very much could i possibly
just jump in there and add to that
um so historically the
um the the funding was um shared
between baber and mid suffolk um and
it's only just
in 2021 that any remaining mon
or any the remaining part of the funding
bid is mid suffolk now
so the prior year figures are correct
and
it is correct that um baba doesn't have
any spending this financial year
but perhaps i need to reword it slightly
differently for the next report
to avoid any confusion if i may
we'll look into it and get back to you
because i i didn't notice the same thing
that 43 000 is there for baber
as a commitment so yeah we'll clarify
this for you yeah
if if i could have that line with just
mid stuff again that would be great
okay thank you we'll do that outside
this meeting
um very nice hang on a minute if i can
just remind
everybody that this is an opportunity
for you to ask questions of
clarification this is not
for debate no no that was that is that
is a point of clarification
thank you this also is a point of
clarification
is feeling of vacancies being delayed
deliberately or is it indirectly due to
the
difficulty of face-to-face interviews
i i would say one word answer both but
i'm i can see that
our ceo also wants to perhaps do more
than a one-word answer
i was anticipating council whitehead
that you might pass this one my way so i
put my camera on um it's predominantly
again because of code it's not a
deliberate
intent to hold vacancies no for all the
obvious reasons we'd far rather have
people in post
but in certain circumstances it didn't
make sense to go out to recruitment
because of the circumstances
that were found ourselves in over recent
months in other circumstances frankly we
were too busy to recruit
bluntly because recruitment itself takes
an investment of time uh but as i said
we have done some successful
some successful recruitment during kovid
and in many respects we've learned a lot
lessons
about how to do that in the virtual
world and i suspect in future we may
well
continue even when we can do
face-to-face meetings may we'll continue
with some of the virtual aspects
um because it's both easier for the
candidate and and oftentimes easier for
us as well but no it's it is a mixture
of both but predominantly because of
because of covert rather than
specifically holding posts
thank you very much chair i've got no
further questions thank you very much
councillor field
everything comes to him who waits i
guess
um just some simple ones perhaps
uh the estimates you're presenting
uh councillor whitehead there is always
talk now of these being
most likely estimates or reasonable
worst case in line with sort of
government
issues i wondered which you think you're
presenting here
which page are you looking at i was
actually looking at page 14 but it was
really um
the the general you you have an analysis
of additional costs and analysis of
income reduction and obviously it's
primary things like the income
reduction that perhaps one could be
making
worst case or most reasonable estimates
and i just wondered which to get onto
something a little more
detailed perhaps looking at uh
page 18 on
paragraph c at the top there's a
a couple of numbers there for the
business rates collection
i wondered whether they were including
this little government's business rates
um holiday schemes or whether they're
there over and above that number
um
[Music]
the waste collection has been asked i
think
i had a couple of others one of which
really ict cost i noticed we're low on
ict costs
there's been a comment during this
meeting about the performance of our
the apparent uh access speeds i know the
county has
whom we've reduced that contract with is
in fact spending substantial additional
monies on
um bandwidth and i wondered whether we
were doing the same thing
and whether that's you know that's
included in those rct
costs and i think perhaps one for the
chief executive the staff cost we've
been talking about you should have
assured us that there
has been no problem that we haven't got
resource i wonder whether we could
therefore look forward to that reduction
in future years
that's it i think council white ted
where would you like to start
well at the beginning i think um you
asked whether it was
in terms of the you know the impact is
it most likely or
reasonable worst case um i think i would
describe it as
intelligent best guess and of course
we're trying to look ahead to the end of
march i mean if someone else can tell me
what
planning will actually be in february i
mean you know it's all just crystal ball
gazing but
i would say intelligent best guess would
uh is i i would like to
sum it up good so not a worst case
thing okay uh look page 18
c and the other
business rates and does that include the
government scheme i
think i know the answer but i'm going to
turn it over to
catherine steele to perhaps give a more
definitive answer for me
thank you councillor whitehead yep the
figures that are referred
to in this paragraph are the percentage
of what we actually need to try and
collect this year
so the various retail hospitality
leisure reliefs that have been offered
this year
have already been taken out of the
equation so this is the
the remnant if you like of the money
that we are actually having to collect
this year
and because of what's obviously
happening in the economy and to
businesses then we're not at
quite uh such a high collection rate as
we would were this time last year
i think the beauty is that when it comes
to collecting it from the government
rather than
business rate payers we actually will
get a hundred percent
rather than the 1998-99 which is
a good thing yes i'm sure you're right
um terms you asked about ict costs again
if i may
pass that over i think to sarah for a
more definitive answer than i can
provide thank you councillor whitehead
yes um just to confirm the um the
numbers that are
quoted in the report as are at the end
of quarter two
obviously there may well be some
additional ic ict costs
as we go through the following quarters
and they'll be reflected in
following um quarter reports or indeed
next year's budget
okay and i think your final question
i've just written down staff costs them
i've got no herb or a question mark so i
can't remember what that question is
sure the chief executive will know what
the question is
yeah it was i just for capsule i have to
benefit i think the question was in
relation to
can we see some of their staff savings
repeated in future financial years in
effect if we've
been able to make those savings this
year and survive so to speak
um i think the broad answer to the
question is yes we would look to embed
some of those savings
i don't think we can expect to see all
of them i think we haven't had a highly
exceptional year so far i think the the
wider point is
it will vary very significantly across
the council depending which service
areas we're looking at
um so if we look at somewhere like
homelessness we are having to invest
significantly in additional resources in
homelessness
because of the challenges we face as we
come out the other side of kovid
similarly i expect to see the same kind
of necessary need in relation to the
economy
uh more widely and then we'd also like
to see a pickup in the economy which
would mean more planning
uh inquiries and therefore potentially
the need for more planners
so it's difficult it's not a straight
line to come back to the kind of
question that was asked earlier on by
council stringer
and it's not a linear thing at all but
we would like certainly look to
where we can make savings then clearly
we would do so
but we also need to reflect the fact
that ultimately as councils we're a
people business
and that's what our predominant cost is
and so we can make savings
in terms of the numbers of staff but
that has a consequence in terms of what
we can do as a result
so finding that that balance is the key
thank you thank you very much sure we
all realize if you make total savings
you get no output
um could i just have one more question
and this is a question
pv panels on page 21 which talks about
an overall variance of 72k
and then talks about inverters 25k
and fit and incomes down 24k those two
may go
together but i can't make 25 plus 24
equals 72.
what do i have this thing maybe it's
just my math is never
that brilliant i think you're missing
the keywords which say the main reasons
all right the rest are all little
reasons aren't they they're
not little tiny weighty ones
thank you very much put out the
maintenance of my pv panels is zero for
the last ten years
yeah mine's the same
touchwood yes
thank you okay thank you so if there's
no
further questions i'm now going to open
up
this item for debate so are there any
cabinet members that want to add to
anything that's already been said
councillor flatman
uh thank you chair i'd just like to um
reiterate what colleagues have said and
i'd like to
um thank the staff and um officers
uh we have absolutely surged on
with our commitment to our district
we have um we've been in meetings
trying to carry on with the um regal
trying to carry on with
the needham market visitor center and
cafe
all our sites are coming forward in the
i mean we have had
so many problems with building materials
and with the workforces some are self
isolating so you haven't got so many
people on site but we have actually
still got on with the day job and all
these sites are coming forth
and we still hope to have the need and
market visitor
site open by the end of summer
when we've spent so much time in
furlough and what have you so well done
to everybody involved
and you know we have to invest to
actually be able to spend
the money in our district and as an
administration i think we have carried
on
given the district exactly what they
need
thank you chair thank you councillor
flatman
anybody else want to come in
okay so i'm now going to ask the
governance officer to conduct the
electronic
vote
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the mod gov
app by going to the plus in the top
right hand corner
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda will now show in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the vote
uh
we are currently waiting for one vote
while we're doing that perhaps
councillor field and council flatman
would mind putting their hands down in
teams thank you
okay thank you all votes are now have
now been made
i can confirm that's nine votes for
so that's the unanimous thank you
thank you very much
so we're now moving on to item nine
which is mca
20 12 and this is the housing revenue
account financial monitoring report for
2020 21 for quarter two
and i'm now going to invite the cabinet
member for finance council whitehead
to introduce this report thank you madam
chairman
i'm pleased now to have the opportunity
to introduce cabinet paper
mca 2012 being the housing revenue
account financial monitoring
2021 quarter two and this starts on page
33 of our report pack
the current year's budget for the hra
assumed a deficit for the year of 564
thousand
now given the many issues caused by
covert we might have reasonably expected
that our forecast now would be truly
dire outcome
but instead we're now anticipating a
surplus for the year
of 1.555 million which is a turn around
a 2.119 million now that really demands
a clear explanation for members
and hopefully i can provide one which
avoids the use of too much
accounting terminology the first
variance i'll bring to members attention
actually puts us further into deficit
we're anticipating a 792 000 shortfall
on rental income
against that budgeted and that figure is
based on the reduction of rent received
so 15
for 26 weeks as set out in paragraph 5.2
now i'm hopeful that a prudent
assessment has a prudent assessment
the bulk of those rents due will
ultimately be recovered albeit
over a longer time frame than this
current financial year
we also have a deficit on sheltered
housing service charges
as we did not actually increase those
charges for 2021
although we had budgeted for increases
overall our hra
income is down 828 000 against budget
on the expenditure size we've made some
six-figure savings in both responsive
repairs and maintenance
100 599 000 and in building services 173
000 these are covered impacted savings
as we could only carry out fewer repairs
and maintenance over the extended
lockdown period to keep both our tenants
and employees safe
so less spent on materials less spent on
travel some head count savings
and the temporary suspension of asbestos
surveys all these contributed to these
expense savings we did spend an
additional 46 000 on ppe due to covert
but we've us set those costs using that
very modest part of the 2 million plus
government kova support grant that i
referred to in my general fund
introduction
however the biggest saving in the year
2.604 million
the one that tips us from deficit to
large surplus
comes from the heading revenue
contribution to capital
so what does that line item actually
mean well originally we anticipated we'd
be either building new houses ourselves
or making acquisitions of new houses
from builders
using 2.604 million from our in-house
income so investing in part of our new
capital stock
without the need to borrow to fund them
our kovit has seriously impacted our
capital building program
we haven't been able to build to the
original schedule at all this year
therefore we won't be using the 2.604
million
so instead it creates an in-ear surplus
which will go into reserves
to carry forward and be available for
future use
so potentially just delaying that
planned investment
the full impact of covid on our capital
program is quite significant
and is set out in appendix a and in the
narrative in paragraph 6
12 to 6 15. so it'll now like to move
the recommendation set down in paragraph
3.1
amended slightly to read that the
council's
housing revenue account financial
position at the end of quarter one
quarter to be noted i'll invite the
cabinet member
for housing to second that amended
recommendation and of course between the
two of us and with housing finance
officers present here to assist we'll be
happy to answer any questions that
members may have
thank you thank you councillor whitehead
councillor hadingham
would you like to second
thank you chair um yes i would i would
like to thank the finance cabinet member
for his introduction to the report on
the housing revenue account
from a financial perspective this is
showing a more positive picture than we
have we could have hoped for at this
point in the year
due to the impact of the coveted
pandemic but we know there are still
uncertainties for the remainder of the
year
in terms of trying to maintain services
too and collecting rents from our
tenants
the impact of what we've been unable to
achieve this year due to lockdown social
distancing requirements
will be taken into account when putting
forward proposals to the 2021
22 budget and the revised hra business
plan
i'm happy to second the recommendations
as set out in the report
thank you thank you councillor
hattingham
so i'm now going to move to questions
from cabinet members
if you'd like to raise a hand
no okay so move on to cabinet
questions from non-cabinet members
no cancer
field thank you
just that overall position question to
make sure i understand we're actually
saying
covid etc has cost us 828
000 but we've
got some repairs service and responsive
repairs we haven't carried out
so the value of about 300 and well
328 000 let's call it it's not quite
that
which leaves us about 500
000 down
and i suppose my question will be that
those repairs and maintenance
are presumably something we will have to
do in the future
and not evaporated
our revenue contribution to capital that
was
202.6 million of our revenue that we
were going to put into
future assets or reserves to
purchase assets in the future
we'll still be doing that but to a much
lesser extent 2.1 million
i'm not entirely sure what your question
is my question is
is this quite as rosy as we're we're
we're assuming that some of the savings
we're making
appear to be just costs that we're
delaying
is that true council whitehead
well i think in so far as um responsive
repairs and maintenance
are responding to repairs and
maintenance that are needed
and have been delayed then then
that it's fair to say that would be a
carry forward built in building services
um there's a whole range of things
behind that
173 000 in total um
in terms of this capital program
i mean i have struggled a bit to get my
head around this because
in in babe is equivalent there is part
saving in this um
capital contribution revenue
contribution to capital
and not over here in mid-suffolk um
if um catherine steele would like to add
a little bit of
accounting magic and knowledge to the
debate i'd be i would happily
uh um encourage that
catherine or gavin for that matter
i'll say i can i can start and then if
if
gavin wishes to come in he can um
what councillor whitehead was saying was
that
we when we put together a capital
programme for a particular year then
there are different ways that we fund it
part of that is from our own revenue
resources which is generated from the
rents as councillor whitehead
says they say this year we've obviously
had lots of impact
into the capital programme for this year
so we don't need to use those
revenue resources some of that
may be required in future years but some
things like the responsive
it depends what goes wrong in a
particular year
so if people haven't needed to have our
services under emergency situations
during the lockdown as we've had it then
that
will most likely be a genuine saving
but where it's more linked to perhaps
our new build programme
then we will obviously be reassessing
how we
use that money in future years going
forward
so we could well be using some of that
2.6 million that is
is surplus this year it will go into
reserve at the end of this year if the
numbers
uh remain the same and then it will be
available for us to
access to fund future years capital
programmes
and saying we will be really assessing
exactly what we need for for next year
and future years as part of that budget
setting process
um but just see if gavin wants to add
anything to that from
the service perspective thank you
catherine thank you chair uh good
afternoon everyone
i think the only comment that i would
like to make and it's really positive
one
um in promoting building services and
promoting their work during the pandemic
members will be aware through previous
meetings that we've discussed at length
the performance and quality around
building services in the past
what the covid pandemic did allow us to
do was actually
rationalize our service um and and take
a
a good look at our existing order book
um so for example at the start of the
year we had seven and a half thousand
open jobs they may have been open some
some
period of time but the pandemic actually
allowed us to
coordinate our resource that we did have
available
and actually close a number of
outstanding older
jobs so actually we're now working with
a work in progress known as the whip
um of a value um and an anova size which
is far
more uh manageable and far more um
expected for the uh level of service
that we provide
uh based on values i'd also just point
out that
what the pandemic uh didn't prevent us
from doing was carrying out
uh void works to empty homes and i think
we were probably
at one point um the only authorities in
suffolk that were able to return
all of their empty properties during the
pandemic so
uh in the height of lockdown 65
properties were returned which obviously
allowed people in in need to to be
rehoused so
the work of the team has continued i
think catherine's made a really valid
point
and one that i would concur with in that
we have had to to manage customer
expectations
customers have been understanding and we
have prioritized work
so therefore some of that work we may
not see in
in future weeks or months
thank you thank you very much indeed did
you have another question counselor
field
no i think i'm fresh out of questions it
answer we're doing quite well thank you
thank you and i think also it's fair to
say that um
some of our residents didn't want us
going into their homes during this
difficult period
so it's not just that we've
not that we've abandoned them in order
to to do other things
they were concerned about people coming
into their homes during this period
council stringer
thank you chair uh during the
uh report uh presentation
it was mentioned that some of the areas
of work we weren't able to do involved
asbestos
can i be assured that this won't
increase any insurance risks of the
council
or to increa increase any adverse health
risks to any of our tenants thank you
chair
that's when i'll happily pass over to
kevin fisk
thank you uh chair thank you council
whitehead thank you uh council string
for the question
um it was uh covert related in that
obviously clearly
there was for a period of time the
inability to access
homes and inspect homes for
asbestos but we have upped that regime
following coming out of lockdown and i'm
pleased to say that there isn't any
significant risks
as a result of um expedient in that
program
the other um element in terms of our
response to
asbestos is that at the uh start of the
year
we made the conscious decision to employ
an additional
officer to manage and monitor our
asbestos spend and our inspection regime
and i think what you're seeing there is
the some of the benefits already
of an officer taking the responsibility
going out carrying out some surveys
working with our two asbestos
contractors who both
inspect and remove asbestos and what
you're seeing is
um already the the uh progress that has
been made by that officer
of that work i mean normally with the
asbestos work we have already
removed all of the very high risk and
medium risk asbestos
what we are left with is is low grade
level of asbestos in our homes
the type of asbestos that you would find
in
for example maybe our tech ceilings
which
actually do not provide or provide a
risk
uh to anyone um if they are not tampered
with if they are not touched
um but that is the work that we are
carrying on inspecting and removing
as and where appropriate thank you very
much
council welum i think thank you chair
this is
probably a very straightforward question
there may be a follow-up
routine maintenance is that covered in
responsive repairs
and maintenance or is it in building
services i'm thinking about
um replacing fences or
painting the outside of a house or
whatever
the sort of programmed housing
maintenance
yeah i think perhaps you can help thank
you chair um
responsive um is obviously
the the work that the team does in
responding to uh
work requests from tenants um obviously
all work is categorized what we have
done uh for next year is actually
try to make it easier for all all
members and or staff in terms of
uh some of the um attribute attributes
that we use in terms of language
um some things like uh fencing
renewal could be uh part of a capital
program
uh but the repair um if you remember we
had did actually have
quite significant storms at the very
beginning of of this year
uh which resulted in quite significant
uh spending in fencing works at that
time
lovely yeah i think and so so that the
routine maintenance is there's a routine
maintenance
program or capital spend
like i mean every house has to be
repainted every so many years
is that the sort of thing that goes in
building services
i presume it doesn't go in responsive
repairs and maintenance
but does it go into capital i just i
just want to understand where
where that money goes where that spend
is allocated
yeah no i understand um so routine is is
your day-to-day
uh repairs um and and improvements
anything in the capital program that can
be capitalized uh would go into to the
capital program
actually something such as painting is
in a capital
uh cannot be recharged to capital so
that would come out of responsive
um or that that day-to-day work program
thank you thank you i'm now going to
open it up for debate is any cabinet
members
want to add anything to what's already
been said
councillor flatman um yes thank you
chair i'd just like to reiterate
um what gavin said about um the voids
etc
as ex-cabinet member
we had weekly meetings and the work that
the
housing um team were doing was
outstanding they were bringing those
voids around because they could socially
distance the distant
um work carry on working but also
he he didn't mention the teams that were
um deployed to um the social um
the um uh the um
oh the the the i've forgotten the name
of the homes now
the actual homes that needed um uh
a warden and we didn't have them so
basically
they were going in and doing all the
cleaning so that was another example of
how they
um absolutely just got on with the job
in hand i mean they weren't trained to
go in and look after people and
make sure they were okay and that also
they were getting
um daily phone calls to make sure
residents
were absolutely okay in those homes so
absolutely marvelous all round um a
great team
and i'm i was glad to um well in a way a
little bit disappointed to hand it over
to lavinia but a great team and they did
a such an amazing job of housing people
all over the place
bringing properties around at the drop
of a hat so vulnerable people could be
housed a very difficult time so
thanks to all the staff and and i miss
you all okay
thanks thank you councillor flatman
um so i'm now going to ask the
governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote
thank you thank you chair
councillors again if you could access
the electronic vote
via the mod gov app and the plus sign
that vote should now be in progress
[Music]
cancel well and would you mind putting
your hand down thank you
we're still waiting for one vote
thank you chair that's nine votes for
so that's unanimous thank you thank you
very much
indeed moving on to item 10
which is mca 20 13
and this is the quarter two performance
report
uh a presentation and i'm going to ask
the assistant director for customer
services
sarah wilcox to to give the presentation
this item is for noting only thank you
good afternoon councillors i'd like to
present mid-suffolk district council's
quarter 2 performance which commences
on page 41. this is the second iteration
of a new and refreshed style format
designed to provide a flavor an overview
of how the council has been performing
for the most part through from july
to september it's a real snapshot in
time
illustrated through some performance
indicators and objectives
which link directly back to our
corporate plan
presentation is themed based on our six
key priority areas within the corporate
plan
communities housing well-being
customers environment and economy
and we also include a theme titled
health of the organization
which really reflects work undertaken to
provide the foundations for us
as an effective and efficient
organization one that's equipped to
deliver our corporate plan
without running through the entirety of
the content of the presentation
i'd just like to pick out a few points
undoubtedly throughout the summer months
there was a real continued focus on our
response to the coronavirus pandemic
with activities highlighted in the
presentation including proactive contact
with high-risk businesses
to ensure that appropriate risk
assessments and working practices were
in place
distribution of over million pounds of
grants to our businesses
and continued support provided to our
amazing community groups and individuals
additionally progress was made against
some of our corporate plan objectives
including drafting and approval of our
biodiversity action plan
commencement of our nvq training program
which was developing
in-house skills for staff to review and
redesign processes from a customer
perspective
we also recruited five apprentices and
commencement of works at our former hq
site in needham market
delivering affordable homes for the
district
as mentioned this is only our second
iteration of this new style performance
presentation
and we continue to really refine the
style taking account of feedback
and making further improvements and this
approach will continue with further
tweaks to future presentations
thank you and i'll hand back to the
chair for comments
thank you thank you very much sarah
so um do we have any questions from
cabinet members
and any questions from non-cabinet
members
counsellor field
thank you it's looking at the the um
section page 48 talks about um
housing and work to improve the quality
of
information we hold about our homes is
nearing completion
and the paragraph about that um
[Music]
carried out we've carried out condition
surveys on half
there's no information there about sort
of what we've discovered
you know we discovered they're all
wonderful or the opposite to that
are you going to report such things
thank you thank you cancerfield
gavin are you able to help with this one
yeah thank you chair uh thank you
councillor field so the the references
to the stock condition survey work
members may recall that about 18 months
two years ago we made the conscious
decision to employ two stock conditions
surveyors
they now visit every property in the
babur and mid-south districts carrying
out
a full inspection of that property
and its component parts as it said we've
uh surveyed um nearly half of of all the
stock now
and what that allows us to do is start
to build uh profiles
of our capital works program uh so this
is
uh re-roofing read doors uh kitchens
bathrooms so on and so forth so that
that rich picture of understanding
exactly what the condition of our
homes is is facilitating some of our
development of our capital program and
what i'd expect you to see
in future years as we develop this work
further
is is quite precise peaks and troughs in
that expenditure based around
the component life of components in
tenants homes
in addition to the work that we'll be
obviously carrying out to
uh make our homes carbon neutral
are you involved are you going to give
us part of the rich picture so we know
that
of our whatever it is one and a half
thousand houses
10 require new roofs or one requires a
new roof or
i'm happy to go away and produce some
some some stats on
what it is telling us in terms of those
components and also perhaps to give
members some awareness as to what this
year's capital program has been able to
uh provide and also what next year's
capital program
is aiming to provide so for example
programs of activity around external
wall insulation
new kitchens bathrooms um some of those
features that that obviously tenants
hold dearly in terms of
their own home so i'm happy to go away
and get some numbers to provide
all members with lovely people could i
just say you know the environmental
group
did ask for some of that data you know
for obvious reasons
one wants to know what sort of spend is
going to be necessary so
as you say how many need external walls
would be great
could i ask one more question really
which is that the stats on
um anti-social behavior page 50
quarter one stats were 28 quarter two
stats were
149 that's a substantial jump and it
uh mentions that you're looking at it
quarter one finished nearly a quarter
ago i wonder
sorry quarter two finished nearly a
quarter ago is there any data yet
who wants to come in on that one
no i think you'll take that one sure
perhaps if i can assist
and to say that i'm not able to give you
any update um
on data but to let you know that yes we
are carrying out a review
um of our antisocial behavior work and
and we have just appointed an additional
officer
um to and to work on cases of
anti-social behavior
thank you but it was a few months ago
and gavin
yes thank you uh chair um thank you
council field
um i think it is obvious that our
councils remain committed
to ensuring that mid-suffolk is a safe
place to live
work or visit um we are aware and are
monitoring the the numbers
obviously all asb and social behavior
complaints are taken seriously
and we obviously conduct a full range of
actions
and attempt to swiftly resolve the
issues
um in the quarter quarterly performance
report there is a no
notable rise in anti-social behavior
particularly
within the council housing team however
some of that can be
attributed to delays so delays from
quarter one
where we actually had staff redeployed
from the housing service
into the home but not alone phone line
as well as supporting the most
vulnerable so that's that's one factor
we've also seen a rising increase in the
number of reports and i think that is
probably
inevitable as uh covid has struck
uh forcing people to stay home for
prolonged periods of time
so maybe there's less tolerance of
uh activity going on if people are at
home for long periods of time
but what i can do is reassure members
that we are building
uh even stronger and closer working
relationships with the police
uh we are trialing and attempting new
methods to tackle asb
so um within the baba district we've had
uh two closure orders um in the past
three months they are the first closure
orders of the councils
and we are developing a cross party
working group to develop
future anti-social behavior policy and
members may be aware
uh of the briefing that uh lee crowdell
tennessee services manager gave to all
members
uh only a couple of weeks ago on not
only the challenges face but the work of
his team to develop new policies and
procedures to combat that
thank you very much
so this item has just been for noting
now um just before we move on to the
next item i just want to remind
non-cabinet members that um
this isn't a discussion opportunity this
is for you to ask questions of
um purely through my my good nature
allowing you to do so um if you have
long
complicated questions um can i suggest
that for the next cabinet meeting
that you put them forward in writing or
submit them under
cabinet procedure rules thank you
so moving on now to item 11 which is the
mca 20 14
is the itic ict
strategy um this went to council
last week feels it feels
more recent than that so this
introduction is
is pretty much the same uh from then
so we we've we've spent um the last 18
months or so
totally restructuring our ict um
following review of the
provision instigated by our assistant
director
sarah wilcox and we've brought in a new
corporate manager for ict
in the shape of matt harding and
restructured the team bringing them back
from
suffolk county council and back under
our own offices direct management
we've strengthened relationships with
suffolk county councils it
to make sure that we get the best value
from this partnership and that we
continue to develop our ict provision
so then a natural progression was to
build a new ict strategy based on these
new foundations
so the focus of that strategy is like
our other key strategies
is about ensuring ultimately the ict can
enable better outcomes for our residents
and businesses and that staff can
fulfill their roles effectively and
efficiently
so this strategy seeks to unlock value
in our existing partnership with suffolk
county council
and our existing software estate and the
building blocks of this strategy are
informed by people
processes and data
so as just one local example think of
the power of the suffolk corona watch
pages online
which most of us have been following
quite diligently over the last few
months
and now imagine that type of data
dashboard applied
for example to our housing stock or to
our claimant
climate change and biodiversity
ambitions
this strategy paves the way by helping
to ensure that
our data is captured and is accurate and
meaningful
so i'd like to take this opportunity to
not just thank our own ict
department but also the team at suffolk
county council
without both teams working in
partnership a lot of what we are able to
do today
including this meeting and the live
streaming of it would simply
not be possible so
after full council um a couple of weeks
ago
we had made a few changes in line with
the comments that were
put forward at that and
um just like to
ask whether there are
i'm proposing whether i've got a
secondary thank you
yes chair thank you very happy to second
the new ict strategy
and thank goodness they were there when
we needed them
yes thank you do we have any questions
from cabinet members
do we have any questions from
non-cabinet members
does anybody wish to debate this
counselor richardson
thank you cher um i'll just be brief i
just wanted to do i think i actually
made similar comments and this came
before the full council
and just wanted to reiterate obviously
our thanks to
um everyone who's been involved in
putting together this ict strategy both
and working in collaboration with um
southern county council and obviously on
our in-house
team as well um because i think there's
there's sort of two
two main aspects of this i think it's
really important one is we should
as um as i think you've said as
councillor flatman said
um that this has been uh hugely
advantageous for us as a council
over the last few months enabling not
just us to reach out and support our
communities during a very difficult
period um but also has enabled from our
perspective our decision making and
local democracy to remain
open and transparent through all of
these virtual meetings
live streaming and now our electronic
voting system as well so all of that's
been enormously important in the way
we've responded
um but also that's obviously it's not
just about covid this is something which
i think we can use in the long run
um to make our services more efficient
and more accessible to our residents
so i think that's something i would
really welcome so this is a definitely a
fantastic step forward thank you chair
thank you council richardson councillor
brewster
i think you're still on mute cancer
brewster
[Music]
that's it sorry um yeah i was saying as
a person
who's really trying to fully understand
it and how it works
sometimes not without some difficulty i
can understand that this it strategy has
helped us to respond to the challenges
that we've faced as a result of the
corona
virus pandemic the use of collaboration
tools like microsoft teams
microsoft forms and cloud-based services
have helped the councils to continue
delivering new and existing services
as you said earlier we are using ms
teams to hold this meeting
have used technology to automate
repetitive tasks
helping to free up staff time so they
can focus more time and effort on covert
responses
we've also used existing tools to
rapidly implement new online forms that
submit
that supported people to apply for
business grants
as a result the core of our strategy has
to ha
stood the test of covid and while from
time to time we may have to change
priorities
around a little as a result the
strategic
outcome absolutely remains the same
that of using the appropriate
technologies to connect our people
and residents enabling them to do jobs
or transact with us more efficiently and
to use data to provide the evidence
of required service change and the
results of it
thank you madam chair thank you council
brewster
councillor fleming uh
thank you chairman thank you i wasn't
actually going to say anything but i
think
i would like to um just make the point
that um i think
um i made a council as well how
important
having a proper functional ict
system is to delivering our climate
change and biodiversity
objectives we we do need to
document our baseline um
and then measure our progress against
that and that all
involves data and how we manage it um
biodiversity mapping understanding what
we've got
that's all part of quite a complex um
probably gis system geographical
information system which demands a
fairly sophisticated
i.t backup i think we've discovered as
we've
embarked on our environment and climate
change
agenda that we really do need to
cooperate with others
and we need to interface with the data
and information that others
have we need to have the technology that
will enable us to do this and be
consistent
and you know therefore somewhat
surprisingly i absolutely welcome this
strategy i think it'll be essential
so um well done putting it together
thank you
thank you councillor fleming i'll now
ask the governance officer
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members
if you go to the vote in your mod.gov
app
vote has now started
[Music]
thank you members chair that's nine
votes for so that's unanimous
thank you very much indeed item 12
is mca 20 15
and this is the community infrastructure
levy
civil expenditure program december 2020
and i'm now going to invite the cabinet
member for planning to introduce this
report
councillor bern excuse me thank you
chairman
um yes this
seal expenditure program contains
an update on progress on decisions in
bid rounds
one to six also included
is a list of emerging projects for
future consideration
which are currently developing
from the cabinet paper there are four
beds with recommendations
albeit the waste infrastructure project
is being deferred and will be brought
back to you
in the spring next year hence there are
now only three bids on which a decision
is required
uh two for cabinet to make and one for
cabinet to note
the decisions for cabinet to make
are um
first one is uh m22
10 which is the creation
of a stone market emergency services hub
incorporating police fire and ambulance
and this will be funded from ring fenced
and local
infrastructure funds this new stone
market facility
will allow for an increase in
operational resources that will be based
at the new facility
and will enhance the level of service to
mid suffolk
when compared to that achievable from
the existing sites in stowe market
shared facilities deliver economies in
scale
and reduce day-to-day revenue costs
clear benefits to the community will be
as follows
there will be enhanced accessibility to
services based from the new facility
target area incorporates a stone market
and the wider mid-soft population
there will be enhanced response times to
end users of the service
provided by the new facility and
the increased staffing numbers and
visibility of resources
that are based in the new facility
a significant collaborative spend has
been achieved for this project
with the monies coming from uh the
following sources
the office of the police and crime
commissioner and
constabulary is
putting up one million six hundred
ninety eight thousand
suffolk county council and suffolk fire
and rescue service five hundred and
eight thousand
five hundred and nine thousand uh and
the dclg
grant is one million two hundred and
forty three thousand
uh this sill bid is for four hundred and
thirty
one thousand or almost four thirty two
thousand
and it represents the final piece of the
funding
that will enable this important
infrastructure projects to go
forward it is listed as essential
in the infrastructure delivery plan and
the infrastructure
funding statement which is the
infrastructure list for mid-suffolk
the sale funds represent uh 11
of the total project cost of 3.8
3.9 million to all intents and purposes
and the final piece of infrastructure
funding
uh that as i say
now enables this project to go ahead the
second
project is m20-9
this is the installation of a sewerage
system
for rinshall village hall the current
connection
torrential school was severed on the
23rd
july 2020 and
this will be from the local
infrastructure fund
the proposal represents an important
urgent infrastructure project
to replace the previous search system
which was jointly shared with the
primary school
and without support and funding for this
infrastructure project
the village hall would not be capable of
use
a planning application has been
submitted for the sewage treatment plant
which has now been granted
this project is being supported by the
community grants team
for eight thousand three hundred twenty
four yes eight thousand three hundred
twenty five
and together with the sale funds of
sixteen thousand
six hundred and fifty one this combined
funding will enable the project to go
ahead
the sale bid represents 67 of the
overall project costs
and accords with financial thresholds
within the sill
expenditure framework this sill bit
therefore represents essential
investment
to ensure continued usage of this
village facility for the benefit
of the community
and the decision for the cabinet to node
is a project at
thornham um
which are works to the thornham works
overflow car park um which was a
previously approved bid of
m19 hyphen zero eight
and this is a top-up bid due to covet 19
implications and this is from the local
infrastructure fund
this bid will enable the previous um
approved project to be completed without
the use of volunteers
which has become difficult in the
current climate of covid19
because due to culvic 19 and the desire
for open space
this project has been has become even
more important
and this small amount of additional sale
monies is 300
3255 pounds
will enable this much needed
infrastructure project to go ahead for
the benefit of
the community the bid represents 74
of the additional project costs and
accords with financial thresholds within
the
sell expenditure framework the project
has been determined under delegated
powers
and it is for now it is now for cabinet
to note only
the works have already started on site
with a partial drawdown of funds to pay
for completed work
so the recommendations as set out in
your reports
paragraph 3.1 please cabinet to make the
decisions at stone market and wrinkle
and note the delegated decision that
sawn
thornham
and paragraph 3.2 cabinet is asked to
note and endorse
the sell expenditure program
december 2020. i'm happy to propose
those recommendations and i look for a
seconder thank you
thank you councillor bernie do we have a
second day
uh yes mr chairman um yes i fully
support these recommendations and more
than happy to
to second them thank you thank you
councillor brewster
do we have any questions from cabinet
members
do we have any questions from
non-cabinet members
councillor field
just a brief one uh windshield village
hall
um what why was the sewage
connection severed was it out of
capacity or
a change in ownership of the school or
what just just uh not that i would
oppose what we're doing it just
it was a interesting to wonder why
um it's a question i've never thought to
us
so i can't give you an answer um
is christine with us or is she still not
well
christian fellow i am here
christine you are christine good can you
answer that question please
why was the um community center
sewage system isolated from
that of the primary school um
thank you uh yes i can answer that
question
um the school became academized if
that's a word
so it became an academy and as part and
parcel
of those changes they decided to look at
their
their sewage treatment plant and do some
improvements
um to their own plant um
the village hall
and the village hall management
committee were offered the opportunity
to go in with that
as a shared facility but the amount of
money that was being asked for
was out of their reasonable
budget means so they decided that
they would apply for cell funds and
community grant monies
to put in their own treatment system
thank you thank you very much
interesting counselor stringer
just glad to note that the field tank
has been
uh postponed to another meeting so i
want to ask a question about
whether that what was actually community
infrastructure uh just getting onto the
uh emergency services hub uh
looking at the guidance uh for community
infrastructure levy
it says that it should be used for
increased capacity for infrastructure
of course stone market already has
capacity for emergency services for
ambulance
fire and police so my question is
do the structures that will be released
from use by this new structure stay
in community use
david christine
um thank you um i'll step
in here my understanding is that the
existing facilities are going to be
offered for
redevelopment of what type i'm not
entirely sure
but the idea is that any
uh monies which are gained from
redevelopment of the site would be
uh plowed back into this project and if
that meant
that um less seal monies were to be
required
then that would be the outcome so
at this point in time i'm
not aware of any intentions for future
use of those facilities
okay that that that's helpful but we
it's difficult to then make the decision
on for you uh for the seal money if it
then may not be needed
if the sites are redeveloped uh i i'm
surprised that's not
known now kind of thing uh okay
could i uh come back on that please they
have factored in
a certain level of return on those sites
uh which um has
resulted in the amount of seal funds
that they have applied for
um but the the idea that if more money
is made
then that money would be returned to the
pot so
the whole calculation has been worked
out on the basis of what they have
applied
to us for still monies on and that would
enable the project to go forward
the proviso that if they make any more
money on those sites so
if they they end up being more lucrative
than first thought uh then we would um
see a return on that ourselves
okay that that's very helpful so can i
then just be assured then this new
facility
will have extra capacity above and
beyond
what the existing three already had
yes if i can come back on that um yes
it will do um there is an extra uh
fire station parking bay proposed in
this
um facility they have also
looked at police requirements and fire
up to the
period of 2036 and so therefore the
proposal is future-proofed from that
point of view
there are also a large number of ev
charging points in here from a police
operational parking point of view
there are up to 13 from a fire
operational point of view there are four
and there are um eight
uh spaces for use by the public
for visitors to the site so um
quite a lot of future proofing from the
point of view of
ev charging points as well
thank you very much so i'm going to move
on now and
open it up for debate to
cabinet members does anybody want to
add anything
counselor hattingham thank you um yes
i'm just like to say how pleased i am to
see some still monies going to improving
the parking at thorne
thornham walks i've been visiting the
thornham estate since i was a child and
it's one of my favorite parts of suffolk
to be able to walk amongst the woods in
parkland there is a very important thing
for our mental and physical health
especially in times like this when you
can feel feel hemmed in
um within your own property it's an
ideal location to visit on your own
with family with children as they're
more than catered for with the excellent
playground
and it's also ideal for taking a dog for
a walk they've always been concerned
with the environment as anyone visiting
their loser will attest
and i see that they're taking an
environmental approach with this extra
car park
using recycled plastic grass
reinforcement mats
which provide strength of the ground for
vehicles and a safe surface pedestrians
it's a no-dig installation mess that
allows the existing grass to grow
through
and therefore provides minimal impact as
well as blending in with existing
existing landscape
so i'm very pleased with that thank you
thank you councillor hattingham
councillor richardson
thank you very much chair um just a
couple of points i'd like to make one of
which i think i
touched upon when i think we had a
previous report uh to the
joint cabinet a couple of months ago um
just to say that it's really
um quite reassuring to see all of that
um
all of those projects coming forward in
appendix a and
how they're being progressed as i say i
think still is a really fantastic
opportunity for us to be investing in
our district
and investing in local infrastructure so
i definitely like to just welcome that
and then just turning to to the
recommendation about which
new projects we want to approve i will
just touch upon the
emergency services hub in stone market
because i think the report that we've
got in front of us does make clear
and that we will see an increase in
operational resources deployed within
the district
as a result of this new site and that we
will see tangible benefits from that so
i note
i think it's in the second bullet point
talks about increased
response times for end users within our
community i know from the nhs
perspective that the east of england
ambulance services traditionally
struggled um particularly in rural areas
meeting some of their category one
responses
when they have to be um yeah you have to
respond within a certain time depending
on how serious it is either eight or
fifteen minutes
and obviously if you consider just that
the size not just of suffolk but of our
district how
how difficult it can be sometimes to
meet those response times
um so i think that having this this
resource this new site with that extra
capacity
and extra resource within our district
within the heart of our district
i think is really important so i will
certainly be supporting the
recommendations in this report
thank you chair thank you very much
councillor richardson
uh councillor brewster thank you mum
chair
yes just following on from um council
richardson
um the my understanding is that the
largest part of the fire services work
now is actually up on the a14
um in some well minor and certainly
major accidents
so they're helping to keep the um the 14
as clear as it can be after an accident
um
but they're from the point where they'll
be leaving they've got very very easy
access
up to the 14 and therefore their
response time
is certainly helped by that um
as i suspect are the police um
that they can uh being stuck sort of in
the middle of stone market
their response time must be faster from
from that particular point where they'll
they'll be housed
very shortly um i i would just like to
say as well that
a big thank you to christine and her
team for the
the actual fantastic work they do in
in managing the seal fund and
and other funding when whenever they
they always look at other funding
it's um uh still being included and
and section 106.
um and i think they they over the period
they really manage
the funds they've got in sil and and in
other areas
so well to to make sure that we get the
the
best buck for our money sort of thing um
so thank you christine and thanks please
thanks your team
thank you council brewster if there's
nobody else wanting to contribute
debate i'm now going to ask the
government's officer to conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair once again councillors
the vote is ready for you
in the mod.gov app
thank you chair that's nine votes for
that's a unanimous
game thank you very much indeed
item 13 is mca 20
16 and this is the thornton neighborhood
plan
and i'm now going to ask the cabinet
member for planning councillor bern to
introduce the report
you're a mute cancer ben not anymore
i managed to do it um
thank you chair and okay councillors
this is
the um uh this this re
report updates you on the progress of
the
thunder neighborhood plan um in your
main report it sets out two
recommendations but i will
when i get to the end i'll i'll
talk about adding a third recommendation
to that
um the two recommendations are that
thornland parish council be instructed
to modify their plan in accordance with
the
independent examiner's recommendations
and the
second one is that subject to
satisfactory completion of the above
the cabinet agrees that this plan be
advanced to a local
referendum now once modified the
thornton neighborhood plan will contain
17 policies
covering housing and the natural
environment the built environment
services and facilities and transport
and highways paragraph 4.2 sets out the
key stages prior to examination and the
examination itself
is discussed in paragraphs 4.3 to 4.5
the few modifications of note are
detailed at paragraph
4.5 and with these and with the
other minor modifications the examiner
concludes that this plan will provide
a strong practical framework for
decision making on planning applications
a paragraph 4.8 you will see
confirmation
that officers are in agreement that all
of the
modifications should be made
paragraph 4.11 reminds us that current
government guidance
remind reminds us sorry yes reminds us
again that
the earliest date on which a referendum
could conceivably take place now
is the 6th of may 2021
now turning quickly back to the
recommendations before you
today i can report that the task of
modifying their plan
is already well underway and should be
completed soon therefore it only remains
for me to ask our officers to continue
to work with the parish council on that
matter
and subject to your agreement today for
this council to confirm its intention
to send this plan to local referendum
um since the
uh since the plan was
sent for examination uh
there has been an interesting um appeal
case heard
at the court of appeal
and it has
caused us to think that as well as the
existing two um recommendations
we should add a third to to that and so
if i may i'd like to propose
that not only do we consider
recommendations one two
but we also uh include three point three
which will push the reasons to strip to
to three point four
and three point three if i can read it
out to you
uh asks that delegated authority be
given to the assistant director for
sustainable communities
in consultation with the cabinet member
for planning
to oversee the process for making any
further
necessary modification to the thornton
neighborhood plan
in line with the recent court of appeal
case regarding the lawfulness
of a local green space policy in a
neighborhood plan
um the the appeal
was was was brought by
a development company that felt the the
um the policy on local
green space was unlawful and
so far as it it was not in line with the
uh the appropriate paragraph it was
paragraph
101 in the mppf
uh and and the reason why it was out of
line it was it it was the policy was
worded in such a way
that the protection it was um
it was placing on local green space
uh was exceeded the requirement
the protection requirement level
that was set down in the nppf the mppf
stipulates that local green space uh
protection
should be in line with the protection
that's afforded
to uh green belt land
and so it's on that basis that
because that decision post-dated the
examination of this plan um
but but is now likely to uh influence
the examination of
uh future future plans that come
forwards
um and certainly will influence the
writing of plans which have yet to to go
to uh
examination so that the policies will be
lawful before they ever get there but in
in this particular case it was felt that
we we should have the
um the authority to retrospectively
alter the the relevant policies
in the or um recommend modification
amendment to the policies already in
the existing uh thornton plan i'm sorry
if that explanation was a little
lengthy and convoluted
but at least it explains to you why
why we are suggesting this extra extra
recommendation so with that
um with that now completed uh
what i need to do now is ask for a
second please
it's uh i'm chair i'm delighted to
second the the report uh slightly
more complicated tasks than i was uh
believing earlier um but i'm i'm happy
to second a report with the additional
recommendation
uh presented by uh
councillor byrne um which is obviously
based
on uh on good advice and allows us
the scope to amend the plan uh
without as is as shown
to be necessary or might be shown to be
necessary without recourse back
uh to the cabinet so that seems to me to
make perfect sense
so i'm very happy uh to uh second the
reportless recommendations
and i'm sure count sistering as the
world councillor i will have something
to say
in support of the plan as well thank you
very much
thank you very much council award
councillor stringer would you like to
add something
as ward counsellor uh yes uh thank you i
just want to
first of all with your indulgence chair
pay tribute to every single volunteer
hour that's gone into this and the good
will that's
been engendered in in the in the
gestation of this plan
that should see uh thornton go to a very
successful
we hope future where a built future that
also built on common understanding
uh to that end though i'm i'm very
concerned about the extra recommendation
uh
in terms of has that been explained to
the neighborhood plan group
uh certainly not been explained to me so
and and and during the explanation
i think i understand the explanation but
it referred to green belt of course
which
suffolk doesn't have a square meter of
so i i'm a bit concerned that we're
amending someone else's plan
to help them but without actually giving
them the due courtesy of telling them
why we're doing it
thank you chair
thank you council
yes um
i i fully understand what you're saying
council stringer
i i i found this out on him myself
just before the weekend and um
i looked up the particular appeal case
court of appeal case in question and
um it does seem to have
changed the um the whole
outlook on the way policies are written
for local green spaces because if the
npps explicitly states that
uh as it does in paragraph 101 um
that the the protection for local
green space should should be the
equivalent of that
given to uh green belt it really doesn't
matter whether we've got green belt or
not
in this in suffolk it's the level of
protection that's given to greenbelt
that local greenspace anywhere
should be able to enjoy and
anything anything that
restricts that or indeed attempts to
enhance it
that's the point of which it becomes
unlawful relative to the
mppf and that's why
all policy writers are now being advised
to
um to make sure that it is comply their
policies
on green space are compliant with the
with the mppf um now so far as the
notification to the parish council is
concerned
to the steering group um i will have to
refer that to paul bryant who i hope is
here who's the
planning officer uh who looked after all
of our
our neighborhood plans so paul could you
could you answer where we are with
notifying or discussing this extra
uh need for for further amendment
to uh to their plan can you come in and
tell us
whether you have made it contact with
them
already or whether that will come in the
next day or two
i can indeed good afternoon everyone
chair councillors um apologies this was
kind of a late thing on for ideas
councillor byrne has alluded to
and he's explained
explained part of the reasoning for this
a lot better than i could
i have been in contact with the
consultant who was employed by
thornton parish council to help them
write their neighbour plan
and he ironically is the person that was
one of the first to alert me to this um
court of appeal case
decision and the
uh potential implications for our
neighborhood plans um
so um he is of the opinion that should
be made
and he is he is in contact and will be
in contact with
those directly involved in writing
writing the labour plan to say
this is you know if we want your
neighbor plan to be
safe and secure going forward this is
the right thing to do
um i apologize to councillor stringer
that um
he wasn't involved in the
very very late on friday evening and a
few emails were pinging back some ford's
first thing this morning but
it's just been
a very very last minute
recommendation table to you lovely
thank you very much paul so do we have
any questions from cabinet members
any questions from non-cabinet members
anybody want to open up the debate on
this
thank you i will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you
thank you chair now
start the vote if you could go to your
mod gov app please
we have two more votes one
and that's unanimous chair nine votes
for
thank you very much indeed so thank you
very much councillors for your
your participation this afternoon the
date and time
of the next meeting will be monday the
4th of january
at 2 30 and that's our first day back in
our virtual office i look forward to
seeing you all again then and if i don't
see you before have a
safe and happy christmas and new year
thank you everybody
goodbye
you